Okay,
one of the things that I've figured out
over the last years is this is a good
proposition,
so you know,
it's pretty self evident that life is
has got its rat's nest of miseries and
that's for sure,
and maybe you could even make a
categorical statement that life is
mostly a rat's nest of misery.
You know,
when you could make a pretty powerful
argument for that,
but then there's a counter question
which is,
well,
what if you tried not to make it any
more miserable than it had to be?
Right?
Then what?
Then what would it be like?
And my suspicions are,
is that lot of misery.
I would suspect that most of that misery
would go away because it's the
unnecessary misery that really brings
you down.
You know?
It's like,
well,
if someone has cancer,
it's like that sucks,
but it's not like.
It's not like you can say,
if only we had done this differently
than that wouldn't have happened,
but when someone's out like torturing
you in a malevolent way or maybe you're
doing the same,
you can always ask yourself,
was really,
is this really necessary?
Is this just like an useless add onto
the miseries of life?
That's what disheartens people,
and so even in your own life,
if,
if you,
if you aren't suffering from self
imposed misery and you're only suffering
from an escapable misery,
maybe you could handle that and you know
who you could,
you could survive,
you could bear it,
and even maybe without becoming
irredeemably corrupt,
so the goal would be,
well,
yeah,
life is a rat's nest of miseries and
maybe it has no ultimate meaning.
We could say that if we're feeling
particularly pessimistic,
but it still leaves one question open,
which is if you didn't do everything you
could to make it worse,
how good could you make it be?
And the least answer is,
well,
it could be tragedy,
but maybe not hell.
And I think that's right.
I really believe that that's the most
pessimistic proper statement.
The worst case outcome in the worst of
all possible worlds is that your life
could be tragic but not hell.
And that's a lot better than hell.
Right?
And you think I could give you an
example of the difference.
You're at your mother's death bed.
Well,
that's tragedy.
Here's another scenario.
You're out of your mother's death bed
and all you,
you and all your idiot siblings are
arguing.
Well that's the difference between
tragedy and hell and you might be able
to tolerate the first circumstance and
maybe it would even bring you closer
together with your family members.
The second one,
no one can bear that.
You walk away from a situation like
that.
Sick of yourself and sick of everything
else too and you know,
it's often the case that tragic
circumstances bring out the dragons
because the stress is high and all those
things that people haven't dealt with,
they don't have the energy to repress
and,
and all the bitterness comes pouring
forward.
So like seriously man it is.
So that's actually a good.
It's a rough lesson but it's a good
hallmark for figuring out whether or not
you're.
You've got yourself adjusted properly
and in relationship to your siblings.
It's like if you were all gathered
around the bed,
if someone close who was dying,
could you manage it?
If the answer is no,
it's like,
well,
put your life together because it's
going to happen and you should be the
person who's there that can do it and do
it properly,
and then maybe you'd find that it isn't
the sort of thing that will undermine
your faith in life itself.
And I've seen,
I've seen both of those situations,
you know,
ugly,
ugly situations,
murderously,
and then they're opposite where people
have had terrible things happen and to
happen to them as a family and you know,
they pulled together and they rebuild
their damn ship and they sail away.
And so that seems to me to be a lot
better.
That makes,
you know,
uh,
when the flood comes,
right?
Well,
okay,
so the same thing.
The question emerges,
well,
who are you?
Well,
you could say you're this plan.
That's what people usually,
that's how people usually identified.
Maybe they have no plan at all and
they're just in chaos,
right?
That's like being in the belly of the
beast.
They're nihilistic and chaos.
They have no plan.
They're just chaos itself.
And that's a very dreadful situation for
people to be in,
or maybe they conjured together a plan
that's their identity.
It's kind of fragile and they're holding
onto that with with everything they've
got.
It's their little stick award that
they're floating in the ocean clinging
to,
you know?
And so they're identifying really hard
with that plan.
That's what happens when you're an idiot
log has that.
You're identifying really hard with that
plan.
The problem is if something comes up to
confront it,
well,
how do you act?
What you can't let go with the plan
because you drown.
When you cling to it rigidly.
Well that's no good because then you
can't learn anything.
Then if that's you,
you're a totalitarian,
you're going to learn anything.
You're going to end up in something
that's close enough to hell so that you
won't know the difference and you might
drag everyone along with you.
Now it's happened plenty of times,
right?
It's the whole story of the 20th
century.
It happened over and over and over,
and it happens in people's states.
It happens in their business
organizations.
It happens in their cities.
It happens in their provinces,
it happens in their states,
and it happens in their psyches all at
the same time.
You can't blame the manifestation of
that sort of thing on any of those
levels.
It happens when a society goes down that
way.
It goes down everywhere at the same
time.
It's not the totalitarians at the top
and all the happy people striving to be
free at the bottom.
It's not that at all.
It's totalitarianism at every single
level of the hierarchy,
including the psychological and so you
don't want to be the thing.
You don't want to be in chaos,
that's for sure,
but you don't want to be the thing that
clings so desperately to the raft that
you can't let go.
When someone comes to rescue you,
right?
You don't want to be that,
so then you think,
well,
exactly what are you?
You're not the chaos.
You're not the plan.
Maybe you're the thing that confronts
the obstacle,
and I would say that's the categorical
lesson of of psychology in so far as it
has to do with personal transformation
because that's what you always teach
people in psychotherapy.
I don't care what sort of
psychotherapist you are,
you're always teaching them the same
thing.
You're the thing that can.
You're not.
You're the planned.
You're the thing that can confront the
obstacle to the plant and then when you
know even further that the obstacle is
not only an obstacle,
but opportunity itself will then your
whole view of the world can change
because you might think,
well,
I've got this planned.
Something came up to object to it.
It's like it's possible that the thing
that's objecting has something to teach
you that will take you to the place
where you develop it.
Even better plant and it's a nice
framework to use.
It's like,
are you so sure that this is a problem?
Is that the only way that you can look
at it?
Or is it an opportunity?
I mean,
I'm not trying to be,
you know,
naive,
optimistic.
There are some things that's pretty hard
to extract gold from some dragons and
maybe the death of a family member is a
good example of that.
But even in a situation like that,
I can tell you that it's an opportunity
for.
It's an opportunity for maturation,
that's for sure.
And the thing is you might say,
well,
it's pretty miserable to go to be
digging for gold when someone's falling
into the grave.
Well,
if they really love you,
first of all,
that's what they'll want you to do,
and second,
you're going to make their death a lot
more palatable experience for them.
If you're someone who can be in the room
and be helpful instead of being,
you know,
quivering in the corner and feeling that
the entire world is collapsing in on
you.
I mean,
that's another.
You want to be the useful person at the
funeral.
How's that for a goal?
That's a good goal,
man.
You know that you've got yourself
together in a situation like that
because you're going to be after and
maybe you want to be the person on whose
shoulder people cry.
That'd be a good goal and it's Kinda,
you know,
I don't like being naively optimistic.
So when I tell you to get your life
together,
I'm not going to say roses and sunshine.
It's like,
that's,
that's Pablum for fools.
But it really is something to be the
reliable person at a funeral.
Right?
And you can aim it that you can do that.
You gotta be tough to do that because it
also means that you can sustain a major
loss without collapsing and that you've
got to be a monster to do that.
Right?